well hello there happy monday my friends
i hope you had a delightful weekend i
didn't but my captors did
so it's big news in the tech world and
bigger badder news for the media but
first let's take a look at google it's a
search engine cat
you can google it
it's now launched an inclusive language
function for their google docs designed
to avoid words that might offend users
for example if you were to type in the
word landlord a warning might pop up
saying it may not be inclusive to all
readers and then give them suggestions
for replacements like property owner or
proprietor or mr furley
i'm still trying to figure out how that
word offends anyone landlord goes back
to feudal systems of the medieval period
and all those people are dead
well not all of them
if you happen to use the word mankind
google might ask you to replace that
with humankind which sucks
i mean what if it's something historical
like jfk's inaugural address google
actually suggested one should replace
for all mankind with for all humankind
man jfk john jr robert joe senior joe jr
ted kathleen ethel david michael must be
turning over in their many graves right
now
i wonder if they plan to censor jfk's
ask what you can do for your country
line because that might offend people
who prefer not to pay their student
loans
so apparently you'll now need to bleach
history to make it fit with a
hypersensitive present which means man
or wife has to go which is kind of
ironic since we're living in a time
where some men are transitioning to be
wives and where some wives are now
traditionally to be men and all i want
to be is a woodland creature with the
power to knit doilies
a nymph
housewife is now stay-at-home spouse
policemen is now police officers and so
on of course many computer systems have
tools to correct grammar and spelling
although you sure wouldn't know that
after reading jesse's book
and what starts on spreadsheets could
probably find its way to your streets
my purse someone stopped this guy whoa
guy we don't need to bring gendered
language into this who cares i'm being
manhandled where's the policeman again
with all the man talk it's like you're
not even listening to me this was a gift
from my landlord okay
first of all it's called proprietor the
property owner and i don't even want
your bag anymore quite frankly and it's
weird that your landlord gives you stuff
[Applause]
she looks good without hair but it seems
like every day big brother is closing in
and it isn't coming from above but from
all sides from creepy journalists like
taylor lorenz the bug-eyed canceled cop
chasing down twitter users to even
former president obama who's launching a
disinformation initiative claiming
there's no right to freedom of his
speech on social media apparently he
still thinks twitter is no different
than other media since it's both private
true i have no obligation to have you on
my show that's obvious
but keep you off twitter that removes
you from the modern town square the only
reason to cheer that is to limit the
flow of information to exclude one
narrative in favor of another which is
what the media does best
and that's part of the big lie it's not
about being inclusive at all this
society is already softer than a tube
sock filled with onion
it's about excluding people whose
opinions counter yours if they can
control language they can control
thoughts then they won't have to spend
as much time indoctrinating your kids
besides who is asking you to change
problematic words it's always one side
and i can bet you it's no impartial
source it's likely someone no one can
stand
and can you imagine how insufferable a
person would have to be to get offended
by these words i'd rather marry amber
heard
we criticized china for their social
credit system but we're getting there
too how long before your bank rejects a
loan because you were spotted at a trump
rally
so yeah big brother is us i don't think
orwell saw that coming or maybe he did i
never finished the book
i didn't even read it got the cliff
notes but it's weird how all this
wokeness only bubbles up from the same
places academia then tech the media they
invent it spread it and use it to
destroy freedom and they all agree
because it's not just words it's power
to control the spigot so stories like
hunter's laptop disappears
no wonder they flipped out over elon
musk and his giant bag of money he
realized the only way to stop this
looming big brother sorry big sister is
to suffocate her with cash
by the way i almost died that way when i
was stripping
his goal to protect not his speech or
your speech but all speech and we should
always be wary of people frightened by
that it means their ideas are bad and
they'd rather shield them and label
competing thoughts disinformation isn't
that right mr obama
so good for musk if he buys twitter he's
just wrestled away the drug that fuels
most of our media and he may in fact
save the town square and not just for
humankind but mankind took
tonight's guest
if you think he looks sharp now wait do
you see him on his electric scooter
radio in podcast host buck sexton
motto is viv and let viv entrepreneur
and author of the book woking quebec
ramaswamy
she's like the milk in the back of your
fridge
white cold and ready to expire foxy's
contributor
and he's required to make a beeping
noise when backing up my massive
sidekick and the nwa world television
champions
high res
all right buck if that's your real name
and unfortunately it is
fair i've yet to meet a single person up
close and personal who demands
replacement words you know what i mean
it seems like it's just some weird thing
that is done behind the scenes with like
three people
well it starts in
places where the left has total
dominance right so it starts on college
campuses
but if you look at the
the words that not only were told the
use but that are new words you know when
the disney chief chief of content talked
about a pansexual child yeah
pansexual explain that and the sex in a
kitchen
the blue check brigade was saying how
could you not know what this is but look
at things like undocumented which people
say all the time now instead of illegal
aliens right the federal term for it for
a very long time they have a long
history unfortunately of getting their
way with this because they're maniacal
and they control the spigots of
information flow although maybe not as
much anymore thank you elon yes i was
going to ask you thoughts on elon big
news huge so my favorite thing about
this well there's it's it's enormous for
what this could do for the future that
that part is very exciting and i know
streaming is in trouble so i would offer
up that there could be a streaming
service where we get to just watch all
the twitter employees and like constant
meltdown right now because they're
tweeting about how you know they they're
crying and they're so upset about this
that the richest man in the world who
has single-handedly built two amazing
companies is gonna be running their
company uh the part of it that i find
fascinating is just if we can get access
to what has been done for the last 10
years
backwards if we look back at what was
done to help the left dominate
conversations over many years on twitter
and shut down things i think they're as
scared of that as they are about what
happens going forward find out why they
why they uh suspended certain people
vivek
do you know elon musk that was i don't i
was just talking to his chief of staff
who used to be a college friend of mine
talking about some ideas and i'm writing
something in a couple of days about this
but i've never met elon no no all right
well he sat back at my place we're gonna
have drinks later that's good yeah yeah
uh what so yeah i i obviously this is
your industry this is your place i mean
it's a confluence of like things from
the woke takeover to elon fighting back
what's your take on all of that i mean
look i'm obviously happy to see him take
over the company i actually think the
hard work starts now though because
there are some really hard challenges
where elon for example has said that he
does not want to see spam and annoying
posts on his feed that ruin the user
experience he's right about that but
some of that's constitutionally
protected so what does it actually mean
to run a free speech platform my view is
actually these are really hard questions
there's one good answer to it as a
principle give the power back to the
user you know what some people might say
that actually my user experience of
twitter was better when i didn't have to
see porn or images or name callings or
racial epithets great go back to the old
old moderation system just be able to
opt into it and maybe if you want to see
what the world looks like without that
then be able to opt out but giving
choice back to the user this is what
silicon valley was built on greg back in
the 1990s they somehow forgot that along
the way yeah just trust people to say
that if you want to be able to see it
you're an adult you can see it yourself
that's what i'd like to see them do yeah
the thing is with that problem though is
that was before things were politicized
like no one thought once politics gets
infected it just like takes over and it
poisons it tyrus it poisons it yeah i'm
poisoned yes what are your thoughts on
anything in particular it's monday well
it is monday
is that after sunday is that one of the
best questions oh yeah it was riveting i
almost feel like i should change my name
to cat because usually
this cat who's left going uh okay so
i'll still book out of your page or a
page out of your book what i what i
found particularly interesting today was
since we're talking about elong and
twitter was how much the press
conference today at the white house was
circled around there and suddenly our
always quick-witted president was very
concerned about what was going on
at with uh private companies
and i thought that was particularly
amusing that how
saki sake zaki saki
dropping a lot of ums and oz about like
watching this very closely and and how
much damage has been done by unregulated
free speech et cetera so i'm i'm
wondering if they're going to try to um
um say i did the sake right there i'm
wondering if they're going to try to do
something try to step in or make it very
difficult for elon to make any changes
at all i don't even think that's the big
story i think the big story was bret
baer saying that
yes
yes i heard it yeah you did okay
okay listen listen listen he did that
for one reason he did that for one
reason and did you not hear at the end
before they went off because the five
doesn't have music either yeah
cat's gonna cry
that's
yes he messaged me afterwards yes i
responded yes it's going to be sometime
next week but don't worry it'll be a
tyrus and timf i'm podcast special
capable of being hurt but also being
happy for you yes
uh what are your thoughts on today's big
news kat
uh i'm actually shocked that it actually
happened what i'm a nice guy
no i mean oh sorry
yeah because every everyone was talking
about like like it actually could never
happen even though that was obviously
what you'd have to do unless you were
just
to screw over all of your shareholders
but people are talking about like it's
the end of the world and now that it
happened i think it's even a little bit
people are actually a little calmer
about it i haven't seen as much freak
out
but you'll see it tonight tonight maybe
i'm excited to see
like the open algorithm idea i think is
really important because they we people
gaslight you all the time saying that
that's not something that exists and
that they don't sort of twist things for
certain narratives but obviously they do
or they wouldn't be freaking out so bad
yeah that's true but let's be real if
twitter died tomorrow would it be the
end of the world no it wouldn't it
wouldn't it would all still wake up yeah
back-up line could just be shut it down
yeah i would say also
i would fire all of those employees who
aren't doing a bunch of work pay the
other ones to leave who would disagree
with them then he's got about like 10
people left build a new company
there's also you know we can get an edit
button finally which people want some of
us want the bots to be cleaned up
because if i'm being followed by an
eastern european supermodel i'd like to
know if she's real no i know was i
surprised when he showed when he showed
up for real yeah she's never real
so far so far tyrus but that could be
not even tinkerbell and wishing upon a
star is going to make that one better
well on that note up next is kamala's
race relationship terse with biden's
wife slash nurse hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else